[Musique]
bonsoir voila ces nouveaux logements qui
doivent donc s'ajouter aux quelques deux
mille annoncées en août par les
autorités qui devrait obtenir cette
semaine un feu vert définitif du
ministère de la défense pourquoi la
construction d'autant de logements
on a su mettre les seuils comme un joug
l'avait bien dit il s'agit du plus grand
nombre de constructions de nouveaux
logements à prouver pas l'état depuis
une décennie le ministre de la défense
israélien benny ganz explique que malgré
ce nombre élevé israël suit une
politique équilibrée de construction
qu'une par israël n'a pas approuvé tous
les plans de construction en préparation
mais offre des offres d'autre part des
concessions aux palestiniens
la raison de cette accélération de la
politique c'est l'augmentation
démographique israélienne
la population australienne augmentent de
2 % par an c'est quatre fois la moyenne
des pays développés
dans la population israélienne doublera
d'ici à quelques temps
et israël est le deuxième pays le plus
densément peuplé du monde
rennes qui avait connu un vif essor un
sous l'impulsion de miami netanyahu
pendant l'ère trump comment les choses
vont évoluer
désormais
grosse avec une telle croissance
démographique une certaine extension est
inévitable
les etats unis ont émis des
critiques très sévères
l'administration joue au pad elle a été
plus clair que jamais disant que cela
était en contradiction totale avec
toutes les avancées vers la paix entre
les israéliens et les palestiniens
les palestiniens eux mêmes ont exprimé
beaucoup de colère vis-à-vis de ces
propositions israéliennes quel est le
regard de nathalie bennett sur la
colonisation
comme
le premier ministre israélien naftali
bennet émane de la droite de l'échiquier
politique israélien et à des vues très
similaire à celle de son prédécesseur
benyamin netanyahou il est en faveur du
développement de la des colonies
israéliennes
et encourage les colons à
continuer leur politique
d'implantation
et malgré les critiques des etats-unis
la politique de colonisation devrait
continuer et devrait se poursuivre dans
le sillage des politiques sous benyamin
nétanyahou naftali bennet cependant en
tant que l'individu
n'a peut-être pas tout à fait le même
point de vue que son prédécesseur
il amène une coalition politique très
fragile
s'est rapproché du centre de la gauche
par rapport à sa position initiale à
droite mais il faut savoir que sa
coalition compte des partis de gauche
des partis arabes le parti travailliste
israélien et tous ces partis sont
résolument contre la politique de
colonisation
donc il fait face à des critiques venant
du sein de sa propre coalition donc il a
un certain équilibre à respecter
car il a une majorité très courte et ne
pourrait pas perdre ne serait-ce qu'un
seul siège à la knesset
donc
il ya un équilibre à trouver entre sahin
volonté d'expansion
et
le fait qu'il doit à maintenir la
cohérence de sa coalition merci paul à
slayer en direct de tel aviv a